while the war in Syria is gearing up to
some sort of a new phase this phase a
new phase is really getting more more
complicated Turkey's invasion the Assad
regime used chemical weapons herds are
carving out their own state look Aldrich
Allah this is ROH Java a region in
northern Syria that runs along the
border of Turkey it's home to over a
million Kurds one of the largest ethnic
groups in the Middle East until a few
years ago this was a rural and forgotten
corner of Syria where the Kurds were
denied legal status by the Syrian
government but today our job is a self
governed region with a powerful militia
that led the fight against Isis and it's
where the Middle East youngest democracy
is taking shape
surrounded by Assad's totalitarian
regime the militant Islamic state and a
hostile neighbor Turkey this is an
unlikely place for a democratic
revolution but it was actually the
Syrian war that made rajamma
a possibility in the first place in 2011
protests against dictator Bashar
al-assad erupted in Syria the uprising
turned into open rebellion after he sent
his army to crack down on the opposition
with battles on multiple fronts and
forces stretched thin he had to make a
choice by July 2012 Assad pulled most of
his army out of the traditional Kurdish
territories in northern Syria to defend
these major cities in the West the move
created a void but not for long an
existing Kurdish political party called
the Democratic Union Party stepped up to
defend and govern the region they called
rojava
they organized it into these three small
self-govern states they set up a
democratic system of local governments
and claimed they were to protect the
rights of all citizens including the
multiple ethnic groups within the region
they also promoted gender equality
across all public institutions including
their military an all-woman military
group called the ypj took shape and
fought alongside the Kurdish militia
called the YPG
[Music]
but just as ro Java started taking shape
it came under attack there's a hottest
militia known as Isis terrorist group
Isis gaining ground in Syria and Iraq
right now and 2014 that the Islamic
state swept through Syria in rojava they
drove all the way to kobani on the
Kurdish border and laid siege to the
city trapped inside were thousands of
civilians and Kurdish militia fighters
as Isis threatened to take the city
small pockets of Kurdish fighters held
their ground until reinforcements
arrived the u.s. provided air support
for the Kurds and together they retook
kobani marking a major moment for Rajavi
the Kurdish fighters proved to be one of
the most effective forces in Syria
leading to continued US air support and
eventually weapons the victory also gave
Syrian Kurds who were denied statehood
for decades an opportunity to strengthen
and expand their territory with Assad
still fighting in the West the curse
decided to take on Isis the Kurds are
the most effective fighting force
against the Islamic state Kurdish
fighters in Syria have made significant
gain killing thousands of fighters and
coring back territory like Kurdish LED
forced launched an offensive today in
Syria pushing Isis further and further
back out of their territory and the
northeastern city for something within
sight of the ISIS stronghold of Raqqa as
Kurdish fighters started liberating
these cities they incorporated their
populations into row Java with the
addition of multi ethnic populations ro
Java was renamed the Democratic
Federation of northern Syria to reflect
the makeup of the region and Kurdish
fighters merged with non courage
militias to form the Syrian democratic
forces also known as the SDF Western
media hailed a moment as the birth of a
young democracy in the Middle East and
the Kurds promoted their democratic
model as a solution for a post-war Syria
the reports also claimed that the Kurds
displaced non Kurdish populations and
committed human rights abuses in the
broader region not ever
supported the Kurdish project on one
hand the Syrian government denied its
existence and on the other Turkey grew
worried as ro Java expanded see turkey
claims the Kurds newer Java or a front
for the PKK a Kurdish militant group
that's been at war with them since the
1980s and is labeled a terrorist group
by the US and the EU so to keep pro Java
from becoming a safe haven for the Kurds
turkey sent ground troops into Syria
here in August 2016 to fight both Isis
and the SDF eventually cutting off a
friend from the rest of the Federation
but the curse offensive continued and in
late 2017 it led to the fall of Isis in
its capital Raqqa the victory marked a
big win for the Kurds but it also opened
up a major threat in early 2018 Turkey
went back into a friend and launched
operation Olive Branch a full ground
offensive against the Syrian Kurds here
with Isis gone rogue Javas partnerships
had weakened and the absence of a common
enemy the American motivation for
backing the Kurdish fighters has
declined especially when they're up
against turkey a NATO ally that the u.s.
relies on now it's unclear how far
turkey will go to keep Syrian Kurds in
check but without us support their
forces are under equipped and
undermanned against turkeys massive
military in this new phase of the Syrian
war where Java has become a vulnerable
target and the Kurdish dream that was
created by the start of the war is
threatened by its end